this video is sponsored by skillshare hi
it's michelle from lab muffin beauty
science chemistry phd skincare nerd and
pigment producing machine
i am super prone to pigmentation it runs
on my family
here is a photo of my dad unfortunately
i inherited these genes my sister did
not so i took one for the team here
i've talked about visible light and blue
light and their effects on pigmentation
in lots of detail before i'll link those
videos in the description
but there's been more studies done since
then fortunately my conclusions are
still correct
in short the vast majority of us don't
have to worry about visible light or
blue light coming from our screens there
just isn't enough light coming from them
but if your skin is darker and more
prone to pigmentation you might have to
worry about visible light coming from
the sun
visible light from the sun in particular
short wavelength high energy blue light
can make pigment problems worse the main
ones are melasma and post-inflammatory
hyperpigmentation so this is stuff like
the dark marks that you get left on your
skin after acne
so today i'm going to give an update of
what we found out about protecting your
skin from visible light
and you might actually be doing it
already if you like nerding out about
the science behind beauty products click
the like the subscribe
and the notification bell so you don't
miss any videos
[Music]
one topic that wasn't very well fleshed
out when i made my first video
was how does blue light actually cause
pigmentation
it's still not super well researched but
it looks like it's mostly to do with
a protein in your skin that senses light
a photoreceptor called opsin 3
once opsin 3 is triggered by enough blue
light
it sends a signal to your skin the
melanocytes in your skin these are the
pigment producing cells to
produce more pigment it might also have
something to do with oxidation and free
radicals but this seems to be less
important
so there are some studies that have
found that some antioxidants can
seem to help with reducing how much
pigment you produce
after exposure to blue light but most of
the focus is now on
preventing that blue light from getting
to your skin in the first place
basically it's on making products that
work like sunscreen
but for blue light
so which products will actually protect
your skin against blue light
earlier research found that regular
sunscreens like the ones that go on your
skin and either go transparent or they
look maybe a little bit white
actually aren't that good at protecting
against visible light
even if you have a thick white layer of
mineral or physical sunscreen
it still doesn't work very well but some
of the earlier studies found that tinted
physical sunscreens gave pretty good
protection
physical or mineral sunscreens are the
ones that contain zinc oxide and or
titanium dioxide
the tint is from iron oxides there are
three iron oxides that are used to make
products look skin colored
these are in things like foundations and
tinted sunscreens these are red yellow
and black
and they're added in different amounts
and different ratios to get the
different shades of skin
a lot of the time they're listed in the
ingredients list as their color index
number their ci number i've listed them
here
and all the iron oxides absorb a bit of
blue light which is how they protect
against blue light
so that's why you've probably heard a
lot about tinted physical sunscreens and
blue light protection
at this point you might be a little bit
confused because if you've watched my
videos before
you'll know that physical and chemical
sunscreens mostly work the same way
they mostly absorb uv and turn it into a
small amount of heat
and they also scatter and reflect a tiny
bit but that amount is really tiny
so why is everyone focusing on mineral
and physical sunscreens
here's where it gets a little bit
complicated it's to do with titanium
dioxide
titanium dioxide is one of the active
ingredients in mineral sunscreens it's
really good at protecting against uv
it also tends to be the ingredient that
gives the worst white cast
one way of getting rid of this white
cast is by chopping up the titanium
dioxide
into smaller particles these are usually
nano sized particles
this makes the titanium dioxide scatter
and reflect a lot less visible light and
so you get less of that white look
and it also actually increases uv
absorption so it actually works as a
better sunscreen filter
but on the flip side it tends to make a
worse at visible light protection
but when you have bigger particles of
titanium dioxide so this is 200
300 nanometers this tends to give really
bad white casts because it scatters and
reflects so much white light
these bigger particles are also worse at
uv protection so they're not really used
in sunscreens
although sometimes they do form by
accident because if you have uncoated
titanium dioxide
it tends to clump together and form
these bigger particles anyway
and that tends to bring down the spf
protection and give
unnecessary white cast but this
scattering of visible light that's so
annoying in sunscreens
is actually pretty useful for visible
light protection scattering means that
the path of the light gets changed
and so instead of taking a straight line
through the sunscreen film
it'll actually bounce around in the film
for a bit longer it takes a longer path
and if you have iron oxides in there as
well then that means there's
a higher chance of it hitting some iron
oxide and getting absorbed before
it gets to your skin these larger
particles are called pigmentary titanium
dioxide
and as you expect from the name they're
used in pigments they're not used as
sunscreens
it's the main color ingredient in things
like white eyeshadow and white eyeliner
but you actually find it in lots of
other makeup products as well
a white color is really good at covering
stuff up it's really opaque
it's used in foundations and tinted
sunscreens to give them coverage
and in fact you actually usually find
more titanium dioxide in these products
than you find iron oxides it's like how
if you have a dark thing and you want to
paint it a light color
you usually cover it up with white first
and then paint the light color paint on
top
so if you see a tinted sunscreen and it
has titanium dioxide in it it doesn't
necessarily mean that it is a physical
sunscreen
if it has these larger particles of
pigmentary titanium dioxide in it
then that titanium dioxide isn't helping
with the uv protection the sunscreen
part
but it is helping with the tinted part
that means that the sunscreen part isn't
actually that important
i mean it is important it's super
important for protecting your skin
against uv
and uv is more strongly linked to
pigment and other changes in your skin
than visible light is
but when we're talking about visible
light it's that combination of
pigmentary titanium dioxide
and iron oxides that's doing the
protecting work
based on that we'd expect tinted
chemical sunscreens to protect against
visible light as well
and yes they do in a study from brazil
the researchers looked at 41 different
tinted sunscreens
they measured how much blue violet light
went through a layer that was 2
milligrams per square centimeter thick
the standard amount for a sunscreen
they found that 26 of these sunscreens
which is almost two-thirds of them
blocked over 99.9 of the visible light
and this included both chemical and
physical sunscreens
in the same study they also tested three
non-tinted sunscreens and they found
that they didn't project against visible
light much at all
and so based on that mechanism
foundations also protect against visible
light
and in fact in a couple of studies it
was actually foundation-like products
with high coverage that gave
better visible light protection than
tinted sunscreens
this isn't too surprising because a more
opaque product will have more pigmentary
titanium dioxide and more iron oxides
in one study they found that a
foundation with spf 35
gave better visible light protection
than a tinted sunscreen with higher spf
protection
in another study they found that visible
light protection wasn't correlated with
spf
so a higher spf product isn't necessary
to protect you from visible
light then why are so many of these
visible light studies on tinted
sunscreens rather than on
foundations i think that it's just
because a tinted sunscreen
is way more practical for most people
who aren't skin care and makeup
enthusiasts like us
a lot of us prefer using two separate
specialized products because it means
that you have a lot more control
over the final outcome how the final
look is
tinted sunscreens only come in a few
shades and so if your skin doesn't match
one of these popular colors according to
someone in product development
then you're not going to have a good
color match it's a lot easier to get a
good color match if you use a foundation
there's also the fact that most of these
studies tested the product at two
milligrams per square centimeter
this is a pretty unrealistic amount for
most tinted products it can make you
look like you've got face paint on
so if you're only relying on a tinted
sunscreen and that tinted sunscreen has
too much tint to
apply the proper amount then you're
going to have less uva
uvb and visible light protection but if
you have a separate sunscreen as well
something that you can apply a lot of
then at least you're not missing out on
that uv protection
but you can imagine how hard it would be
for a dermatologist to convince someone
who
isn't using either sunscreen or makeup
to suddenly start using both
it's much easier to convince them to
start using a single product and this is
the direction that most companies seem
to be heading in
hopefully the extra focus on tinted
sunscreens means that they'll start
making more shades
and the fact that visible light affects
people with darker skin more
hopefully means that they'll put more
effort into making darker shades that
actually match darker skin
this isn't really something the beauty
industry has been really good at so far
so i'm not sure how optimistic i should
be
so in short if you want to prevent
pigment from the sun your best bet is
high uva protection and a tinted product
with heavy coverage
that can be a sunscreen and a separate
concealer or foundation
or a tinted sunscreen that goes on well
and like with uv there are other ways to
avoid visible light exposure that's not
just sunscreens and if you use them with
sunscreens it tends to work better
so i'm talking about things like staying
in the shade during the middle of the
day when it's the sunniest
and using things like hats and clothing
to protect your skin
i hope you liked this video if you did
click the like the subscribe also leave
me a comment letting me know what else
you want me to talk about
you can follow me on instagram tiktok
and check out my blog as well
thanks to skillshare for sponsoring this
video and for allowing me to make
super nerdy deep dives into pretty much
anything i want which is honestly so
nice of them
skillshare is an online community that
has thousands of classes
on lots of topics like design
photography web development marketing
and analytics
most of the classes are less than an
hour so it's really achievable to learn
something new
even with a tight schedule i recently
became obsessed with houseplants
i know this is peak pandemic millennial
and yes i also got a tool recently that
lets me make smash avocado on toast
really efficiently
anyway it turns out skillshare has a
whole bunch of classes on how to look
after house plants
i went to an agricultural high school so
i thought i knew a lot about plants but
it turns out that knowing how to grow
200 acres of radishes isn't really the
same as keeping a house plant alive
i learned a lot from chris sach who is a
botanist his class is called happy house
plants caring for your plants
apparently you're meant to throw out
dead leaves and not just let them drop
into the pot
and rot and do the whole circle of life
thing the rotting leaves can actually
attract pests
and cause disease so now i can stop
feeling bad about micromanaging how my
plants look
i'm not being a shallow stage mum i am
helping if you want to check out
skillshare
the first thousand people to click the
link will get a free trial or skillshare
premium
it's normally less than 10 a month with
a yearly subscription
thanks for watching